Okay. So, um, Thursday,
less long ago, last week,
um,
we began to set the scene for this
course by talking about the experience of
being a British colonist.
And as you remember,
we talked about the connection
the colonists had with England,
both positive and negative.
We talked about their sense of England
and particularly London is being the sort
of center of the empire and
almost the center of the universe.
And we talked about the colonists,
simultaneous concerns about maybe not
quite being as good as the people who were
at that wonderful sophisticated
center of the universe. Um,
and I closed the lecture by noting that
in many ways the colonists were never as
British as when they began to object
and then ultimately rebel against their
mother country for not being given
their full rights as British subjects.
Okay.
So if Thursday's lecture was about how
the colonists identified with the mother
country,
today's lecture sort of does the opposite.
And what I'm going to be talking about
today is the ways in which the colonists
and the colonies were different from
people back in the mother country.
Basically is the title of this lecture
suggest I'm going to be talking about
being a British American as opposed
to being a British colonist,
which is last week now connected
with what I suggested on Thursday.
It's important to note that the American
colonists weren't necessarily aware of
the ways in which some of their ideas
and attitudes were different or certainly
we're evolving differently
from those in England,
and I'll come back to this
again in this lecture,
but I'll mention it here
by the mid 18th century,
the period that we're
really talking about now,
there had already been several
generations of colonists in the colonies,
so certainly there were people in the
colonies who themselves had never been to
England, perhaps didn't know very
many people who had been to England,
and so they didn't necessarily have an
amazingly accurate sense of really what
it meant to be a British
subject in England living
in England proper as opposed
to their experience of
being in the colonies.
And that's going to be an important
thing to think about as we continue on in
this course. This idea that ideas are
evolving differently in the colonies,
then they're involving in England and
the colonists didn't necessarily realize
that these differences existed.
Okay,
so I want to begin this lecture on being
a British American with just a handful
of examples and really kinds of snapshots
of life in the colonies in the 1740s
and as you'll see with
these little examples,
they're going to each be demonstrating
something that I'm going to come back to
later in the lecture,
but I at least wanted to give you sort
of a sense of what it looked like before
I actually talked about it and
I've pulled all of these examples.
There's three or four of them
all from the same source,
which is from a really well known
diary by a Dr. Alexander Hamilton,
and this is not the Alexander Hamilton.
I always feel bad for this guy because
he's gone down to posterity is like not
the real Alexander Hamilton.
He's, he's the not real, he's
the unknown, unimportant.
Alexander Hamilton for guy who lived in
Maryland is a doctor and actually mean
does have a really interesting diary.
I'll be reading a couple of sections from
it. Um, but he's, he's not the founder.
Tough break for Alexander
Hamilton. Okay. So in 1744,
he decided to take a trip north from
Maryland for his health and that's when he
keeps this sort of a travel diary.
And in it he recorded his observations
with a lot of detail as you'll hear that
show a lot about habits of behavior and
thought in the colonies are certainly,
and they also will show you a lot as
you'll see about Mr. Hamilton. Um,
but also they,
they sort of show you what he
saw through the lens of him. Um,
but still they'll give you a sense
of some trends. Okay. Um, and I'll,
I'll actually, I'll add here one
little brief point and that is,
I'm in a sense this is
touching on something that
I'm going to be focusing on in
Thursday's lecture. And that's the
idea that, um, too many people,
and you'll hear it sort of underlying
what he's saying here. Too many people,
their individual colony really was
what felt to them like their country.
And people often refer to Jefferson
called Virginia my country well into the
1790s if not beyond.
So you'll be hearing how people really
feel about their colony versus those
other foreign colonies.
People often felt as though they were
different countries with strange habits
and weird speech patterns.
So you'll,
you'll kind of hear that beneath what
I'm going to read here by Hamilton. Okay.
So one thing that Hamilton wrote about
in his diary shows the impact of the
great awakening during the
time that he was traveling,
which is the 1740s the colonies were
actually right in the middle of the great
awakening,
which was this really vast religious
revival that really swept through the
colonies.
And in the course of Hamilton's travels,
he said he could always tell when he
came across the revivalist because they
always had a really dour expression on
their faces that they were just about to
ask you to repent for your sins.
So he says at one point he came
across one of these revivalists.
He said the fellow was named Mr.
Thomas Quiet and is Hamilton,
put it in his diary.
This fellow I observed had a
particular down hanging look,
which made me suspect that he's one
of the revivalists, I guess right for,
he introduced a discourse
concerning George Whitefield,
who is the renowned preacher
of the great awakening.
He traveled throughout the colonies
preaching and in a lot of ways he was sort
of the guiding force behind
the great awakening in America.
So Mr. Thomas Quiet,
enlarged pretty much and with some
warmth upon the doctrines of that apostil
speaking much in his praise.
I took upon me in a ludicrous manner to
impugn some of his charming. He's like,
oh, since this means a lot to
him, I'll just make fun of it.
Which by degrees put mister quiet in a
passion and he successfully upsets mister
quiet. He told me flatly that I
was damned without redemption. Ah,
really fun conversation.
I replied that I thought his name and
behavior were very incongruent and desired
him to change it with all speed
where it was very improper.
That's such an angry turbulent mortal
as he should be called by the name of
Thomas Quiet. Okay. This tells you
a lot about Alexander Hamilton.
He just as you'll hear, he doesn't
sound like it, really charming fellow,
but certainly that passage gives you a
sense of the sort of religiosity that
mark this particular period.
Okay.
So sometime later Hamilton met three men
from Pennsylvania and he decided he was
going to treat them to punch
in an off roads tavern.
Now to Hamilton is you'll hear clearly
these three men were not gentle men are
certainly, he assumed that they were
beneath him. Um, as he noted in his diary,
one of them seem to have to think really,
really hard about every word
that came out of his mouth.
One of them was fused in compliments
which were generally blunt and came out in
an awkward manner.
And the third one was a very
rough spun forward clownish blade,
much addicted to swearing
at the same time,
desire is to pass for a gentleman
not withstanding which ambition the
consciousness of his natural Boris and
Boris snus obliged him frequently to
frame.
Ill timed apologies for his misbehavior,
which he termed frankness and freeness.
It was often quote damn me
gentlemen and excuse me Y'all,
I am a plain honest fellow.
All is right down plain dealing by God.
So he manages to apologize and
swear in the same sentence,
which is pretty tricky.
Now that fellow,
what Hamilton refers to as the sort of
odd cursing fellow went onto curse Sir
Robert Walpole who was a recent British
prime minister as a rascal and is
Hamilton put it. We asked him his
reasons for cursing Sir Robert,
but he would give us no other than this
that he was certainly informed by some
very good gentlemen who
understood the thing. Right.
Well that the said Sir Robert
was a damn rogue. So you must be,
well important gentleman
have told me he was.
He must be and I will
now quote it to anyone.
I meet at random taverns
by the side of the road.
So here you see three average people
try and clearly or at least to Hamilton,
try and clearly to impress
or please him in some way.
Clearly he is sort of snarky it feeling
as though he's above them in social
status is tavern companions feel a little
bit awkward there apologizing all the
time and saying,
well I'm just a plain speaker.
All of which Hamilton
clearly fines amusing.
And this anecdote suggest two things.
First it shows people of
different social ranks,
obviously socializing and show several,
well what Hamilton would've considered
common folk trying to in his mind pass
for gentlemen.
But second you see a group of people who
all perceive differences in status on
all sides.
So they're hanging out together,
but they also understand that
there's a little bit of a difference.
It's making them feel somewhat
awkward. Okay, so at another tavern,
Hamilton is going to ever get tavern,
I guess this portion of
the trip at another tavern,
he said he died with a very mixed company
of different nations and religions.
There were Scots, English, Dutch, Germans,
Irish, Roman Catholics, church man,
Presbyterians, Quakers, New Light man,
Methodist, seventh day men, Moravians,
Anabaptist and one Jew
counted that one guy.
So obviously here you see diversity,
great diversity of all kinds of
religious diversity, ethnic diversity.
Which also represents something that
was typical of the colonies in a general
way though more in some places than
in others. And actually Pennsylvania,
which is where I think
he is at this point,
was known at the time for being
particularly diverse. One last anecdote,
so at one point he even says he
ended up in a conversation with some
Pennsylvanians about how low Maryland
was in comparison with Pennsylvania,
which clearly was a much better
colony as Hamilton put it,
the Pennsylvania's enlarge upon the
immorality, drunkenness, rudeness,
and immoderate swearing. So much
practiced in Maryland and added that,
no such vices where to
be found in Pennsylvania.
I heard this and contradicted it.
Not because I knew that the first part
of the proposition was pretty true.
He's like, yeah, we are drunk and we do
swear a lot and were rude in Maryland, so,
okay.
I think that's true,
but what appeared most comical in their
criticism with they're making a merit of
the stoniness of the roads as one put it,
one may ride 50 miles in Maryland and
not see as many stones upon the roads.
That's 50 paces of roads in Pennsylvania.
This I knew to be false, but as I thought
there was no advantage in Stoney roads.
I let them take the honor of it to
themselves and did not contradict them.
Now to me, one of the interesting
things about this anecdote it,
it makes me think about almost a century
later when we're talking about de
Tocqueville and he's wandering around
America talking with random Americans.
And one of the things that drives him a
little bit nuts is that no matter what
American he talks to,
no matter where he is,
the American always tells him how
everything is best in America better than
anywhere else in the world.
So what Tocqueville is
witnessing in the middle of the,
towards the middle of the 19th
century is national pride.
And what you're seeing here is
a close equivalent equivalent,
but obviously it's colonial pride is
pride in your own individual colony.
And in a sense, again, it's a reminder
that people are seeing their colony,
colonies, their country. So in all
of these little, these snapshots,
these anecdotes, we've seen a few
things about life in the colonies.
We've seen religiosity and the
impact of the great awakening.
We've seen diversity of all types.
Sometimes at one dinner table we've seen
a middling society and we've seen how
people saw their own colony
as their own country.
And in a sense other colonies is other
countries to varying degrees and all of
the colonies,
all of these things were characteristic.
So with that introduction,
I want to turn out to really look at
what was different about the American
colonies.
Why were people here different?
Why was life here different from what
it would've been like to be a British
subject back in England?
So that's going to be what I mainly
address for the rest of the lecture.
And I'm going to talk about it by
focusing on three different points.
Point number one,
I'm going to talk a little bit about the
distinctive character of the people who
migrated to the colonies.
It gives you such a sense of power when
you're lecturing and you say there are
three reasons and the entire room
goes, oh, free. There are three.
Uh, so there are three. Um,
so number one is the distinctive character
of the people who migrated to the
colonies.
Number two is the distinctive
conditions of life in British America.
And that, that point I'll
talk about for the longest.
And then number three is the nature
of British colonial administration.
And I'll repeat that.
The distinctive character of the
people who migrated to the colonies,
the distinctive conditions of life in
British North America and the nature of
British colonial administration.
So let's start off first by looking
at that first category of difference,
the character of the people
who migrated to the colonies.
And as you'll see in some ways a
distinctive kind of person migrated to the
colonies, or at least tended to in, in,
in ways that will make perfect sense.
So for one thing, and in a way this
sounds obvious, once you think about it,
people who migrated to the
colonies tended to be risk takers.
These were people who are
willing to take a risk.
They were willing to make the
hazardous passage across the sea,
put themselves at a
distance of several months,
travel from everything that
they knew and start life anew.
And what they assume to be
some kind of a wilderness.
There were people who wanted something
maybe to better their condition and they
weren't afraid to act on
that desire to reach for it.
Obviously these are people who are going
to be pretty independent and they were
often people who didn't
simply accept the status quo.
Now all of these are really big,
broad generalizations,
but as big as broad as they are,
you can see in a general sense that
people who are deciding to migrate in this
way,
it's certainly many of them would have
shared some of these characteristics to
some degree and as we're going
to see in the next few weeks,
in a general way, this spirit
ran through all of the colonies.
This sort of sense of really being
willing to push for what you wanted in the
old world.
Naturally enough things were more
tradition bound in the new world just by
deciding to go to the colonies.
You were already breaking with tradition
and behaving differently from the
average British subject.
So if you put this different sort of
person in a different kind of environment,
as in the colonies,
you begin to understand the slow creation
of something that ends up being a kind
of colonial American mindset or mentality.
And this brings us to my second
category of differences in the colonies,
which is the conditions of
life in British North America.
You have a different kind of person now
you're putting them in a different kind
of living situation.
And there were a number of things that
were different about living conditions in
the colonies. First, as
I mentioned last time,
more people on land in the
colonies there was a lot of land,
I mean empty land,
some of it actually empty land,
some of it land owned by Indians
that people considered to be empty,
but there was more land that was
certainly accessible to settlers in the
colonies.
So these risk take taking types who came
to the colonies could get land and set
up their own farms a lot more
easily than they could in England,
which gave more people a more independent
lifestyle in the colonies and a sense
that they could be and maybe we're raising
themselves up in the world in a way
that might not have been as
easy to do back in England.
A second difference in living
conditions involve voting and political
participation because logically enough,
and generally speaking,
land holding in the
vote went hand in hand.
The idea being in the colonies that you
should only let people vote who were
really invested in a community.
And land holders holders are pretty
literally invested in their communities.
So in the colonies where you have a lot
of a much larger number of landholders,
you have a much wider franchise than
in England. So an example of that,
in the 1760s in England,
roughly 20% of white men had
the vote in the colonies.
Roughly 60 to 80% of white men had
the vote depending on the colony,
which is a pretty big difference.
And that one fact alone represents a
big shift in mindset and the colonies.
You had lots of landholders who knew
that they had the right to be directly
involved in the political process.
Equally important,
not only were more people able to
be active in the political process,
but the process in which they were
taking part was really localized.
So people felt able to
understand an effect.
That process a lot of times you knew,
or at least perhaps had met many of the
people that held government offices and
elections could be won or lost
by just a handful of votes. Now,
when I first taught this course,
that that always used to be
like an amazing fact. Wow.
And election could be lost by a handful
of votes and somehow in the last 10
years, that doesn't seem amazing
anymore. We do that all the time now.
I don't know why that happens.
Okay,
so I want to look for just a couple of
minutes at how voting actually worked in
the colonies. And it varies
from colony to colony. So again,
I'm talking in a general kind of
way here. Elections. First of all,
and this is generally true in all of
the colonies they had to take place over
the course of a few days because people
were often traveling from very far away
to get to a polling place.
And once they got there,
because it was such a big deal for
people to get to a polling place,
they generally discovered what in
essence was a kind of affair. I mean,
election day was big
sort of celebration day.
There are a lot of people milling about.
There was a lot happening,
there was a lot of alcohol.
The alcohol was provided by the
candidates here, you must vote for me.
I have another.
And the candidates can
would've been prison to helping
to poor and mingling with
prospective voters. Now a couple of years
ago, I mean I knew this fact for myself,
I hadn't ever sort of thought
about how it played out.
And then a couple of years ago I was
researching in the Virginia historical
society. I was of course
looking for something else.
But when I came across was a bunch of
documents that clearly involves some kind
of legal dispute that broke out because
of a problem on one of the election days
in Virginia. And apparently
what happened was, um,
the brother of one of the candidates
showed up with a pack of his friends,
drank a lot,
got really drunk and then stood at the
door of the polling place with guns and
threatened to shoot anyone who didn't
vote for the brother of a guy standing,
you don't vote for my brother,
you die.
Strong persuasive component.
Um,
so obviously at least in that election
you had drinking, celebrating and guns,
which is a bad combination,
but,
but elections were really kind of rowdy
occasions now what that kind of hints of
that sort of door persuasion is that
actually once you went into the polling
place, assuming that you
weren't shot first, um,
there were no secret ballots.
You actually step to the front of the
room and usually it was a table at the
table was sitting the candidates
and maybe some official,
perhaps like a local sheriff.
And you declared who you voted for in
front of everybody and in front of the
candidates.
So one example actually from a document
from the time period we're in Virginia
and one voter, uh, Mr. Blair came forward
to this table and the front of the room,
candidate on each side of the table,
the sheriff in the middle and the
sheriff says, Sir, who do you vote for?
And Mr. Blair says,
Mr. Marshall and Mr. Marshall responds,
your vote is appreciated, Mr. Player, it's
very personal exchange. The next voter,
I'm Mr. Buchanan is asked
the same question and he
says that he votes for Mister
Clapton and Mister Clapton responds,
Mr. Buchanan,
I shall treasure that vote in my memory.
It will be regarded as a feather in my
cap forever. That's such a politician.
He's like already you can hear.
So obviously this is a very personal
process and which certainly you could feel
some pressure to vote a certain way.
It's actually a surprisingly long period
of time before people figured out that
maybe ballots are great idea.
Maybe voting in person is not so good.
Okay,
so you've got more land holding in the
colonies leads to a broader franchise in
the colonies. You have voters
taking part in a very localized,
immediate political process.
Another significant difference in
colonial conditions of life connects with
something that I've mentioned briefly
on Thursday and that's the nature of the
colonial social structure.
As I mentioned last week,
you did have an elite in the colonies,
but the proportions of elite and
laboring people's with was different.
In England, half of the population
roughly was of the laboring class.
People who did not own land
and labored for others,
and the other half of the population which
included small farmers and the gentry
and nobility owned most of
the land in the colonies.
Two thirds of the white men
owned land or businesses. Again,
which gives you a sense of why the
colonies are often known as a sort of
middling society.
Also in the colonies,
there wasn't such a stark contrast between
the top and the bottom of the social
spectrum.
So in England you had the royal court
who have courtiers and opulence and court
ritual and sort of cow to the king.
At the very top of the social spectrum.
Obviously the colonies did
not have something like that.
They did have royal
governors and certainly royal
governors lived in fine style
in comparison with others,
and there was certainly a distinction
between average people and gentlemen,
but the contrast between governors and
farmers was nowhere near the extreme
contrast between a member of the
entrenched British nobility and a landless
commoner. So in America, the spectrum,
it's like the top of the bottom of that
spectrum have been sort of locked off
and what's in between is
a little bit more pliable,
so more landholding, broader franchise
and everything that that entails,
more of a middling society and now yet
another colonial difference that I hinted
about at the start of today's lecture.
The fact that several generations of
colonists had lived and died in the
colonies having never been to
England by the mid 18th century,
you had a colonial society full of people
who often had no actual personal tie
to England except an emotional tie.
And I talked about those
emotional ties last week.
So just think about this comparison,
the length of time between
the first settlement at
Jamestown and the declaration
of independence is roughly the same
as the length of time between the
declaration of independence
and World War II. Okay. We,
we tend to collapse all of early America
into one big blob of early America.
And we assume it's a
kind of a small blurb.
But if you think about that declaration
of independence to World War II,
Jamestown to the
declaration of independence,
we are talking about a
broad expanse of time.
So these people,
or at least many of them are truly
British Americans at this point
because we're also not
Britain's and yet another way,
another distinctive feature of
colonial society. And that's again,
something I referred to at the beginning.
And that's the great ethnic and religious
diversity as our friend Mr. Hamilton,
or Dr. Hamilton was noting
there were immigrants from
Germany, Scotland, Ireland,
there were Quakers,
they were Roman Catholics,
congregationalists and then
later on Methodist and baptist.
So generally speaking,
it's a reasonably pluralistic society
with a relatively high tolerance for
diversity.
Though new Englanders in some ways,
particularly in early colonial times,
are a little bit less tolerant
related to this diversity is yet another
colonial distinction and that's the
religiosity in the colonies, which is
really heightened by the great awakening,
which was roughly from the 17 thirty's
to the 1760s now I've said that,
but what I really want to also point out,
I'm not saying that the great awakening
is a purely colonial phenomenon because
it isn't and as a matter of fact,
it's spread to the colonies
from England and from Ireland,
but it's impact on the colonies would
be different when you combined it with
some of the other things that
were distinctive about colonials.
Society in life is, I'm talking
about here now. We can have it.
We can have a little Yale moment here.
I'm always looking for Gayle moments.
It's a little Yale moment because Jonathan
Edwards is someone of importance in
the spread of the great awakening.
His preaching really sparked the New
England branch of the great awakening.
Edwards preached that God was Raffle,
that endless torture awaited the sinner,
but God was also loving and wanted
sinners to convert and turn towards God's
love.
And most important you could choose
heaven or hell depending on whether you
chose to repent. And I can't resist.
Whenever I get to this part of the course,
I can't resist offering a little snippet
of one of Edwards' most famous sermons,
which is sinners in the
hands of an angry God.
How many of you have read a good number
of you have read as a great sermon?
1741 I,
I can't resist giving you your own great
awakening moment because that means I
get to actually be Edwards for a little
bit in order for you, the wrath of God.
So, um, I will offer you a tiny
snippet from Edwards sermon.
I think it's different when you
hear it from when you read it.
The God that holds you over the pit of
hell much is one holds a spider or some
loads,
some insect over the fire of whores you
and just dreadfully provoked his wrath
towards you.
Burns like fire.
He looks upon you as worthy of nothing
else but to be cast into the fire.
He is a pure eyes than to
bear to have you in his sight.
You are 10,000 times more
abominable in his eyes.
Then the most hateful
venomous serpent is in ours.
You have offended him
infinitely more than ever.
A stubborn rebel did his prints and yet
it is nothing but his hand that holds
you from falling into
the fire every moment.
It is to be a scribe to nothing else that
you did not go to hill the last night,
that you were suffered too awake again
in this world after you closed your eyes
to sleep and there was no
other reason to be given.
Why you have not dropped into hill since
you were rose this morning and that
God's but that God's hand has held you up.
There is no other reason to be given
while you have not gone to hell since you
have set here,
oh center,
consider the fearful danger you are in.
You hang by a slender thread with the
flames of divine wrath flashing about it.
Ready every moment to singe
it and burn it asunder.
And you'll have no interest in any
mediator and nothing to lay hold up,
save yourself, nothing to keep off the
flames of wrath, nothing of your own,
nothing that you have ever done,
nothing that you can do to induce
God to spare you one moment,
I think, wow, that's sermonizing.
That's like pow in your face urbanizing.
So that kind of is the core
of the great awakening, right?
This belief in the sinfulness
and helplessness of
humankind and the possibility
of redemption.
If you individually make the choice
and repent and as suggested by Edward
sermon,
they were often some tearful emotional
conversions at the big camp meetings that
took place at this time.
And I actually have an eyewitness
account of a camp meeting,
which I offer you partly
because as you'll see,
there's an aspect of it which I
consider truly ridiculous, but it's,
it's offered by Benjamin Franklin,
which I also think is interesting.
And you'll see the enlightenment and the
great awakening come up right against
each other in this little passage.
Franklin actually is in Pennsylvania and
he says he sees Whitefield preaching to
a crowd as he describes it.
In 1739 arrived among us from Ireland,
the Reverend Mr Whitefield,
who had made himself remarkable.
There is an itinerate preacher.
He was at first per minute to
preach and some of our churches,
but the clergy taking a dislike to him
soon refused him their pulpits and he was
obliged to preach in the fields.
The multitudes of all sex
and denominations that
attended his sermons were
enormous and it was a matter
of speculation to me who
was a vet. Number two,
observe the extraordinary influence of
his oratory on his hearers and how much
they admired and respected him.
Not withstanding his comment,
abuse of them by assuring them that
they were naturally half beast and half
devils being among the crowd,
being among the hind most of the crowd.
So he's towards the back of the crowd.
I had the curiosity to learn how far he
could be heard by retiring backwards.
Okay,
so now Franklin says,
I wonder how far I could back away
and still hear him preaching clearly.
Clearly at this moment, he's not
really thinking about the message.
So I backed away towards the river and I
found his voice distinct till I came to
your front street when some
noise on the street obscured it,
and at this point you can really hear
that the sort of enlightenment come
banging up against the great awakening,
imagining then a semicircle of which my
distance should be the radius that it
was filled with auditors to each
of whom I allowed two square feet.
I computed that he might well be heard
by more than 30,000 this reconciled me to
the newspaper accounts of
his having preached to 25,000
people in the fields and
to the histories of generals,
haranguing whole armies of
which I had sometimes doubted.
So he computes out radios and area.
Wow.
We could actually be preaching
to 30,000 people now that said,
Franklin says by the end of the sermon
when clearly there was a collection plate
that was going to be passed around,
Franklin said, I first silently resolved.
He should get nothing from me. I had
in my pocket a handful of copper money,
three or four silver dollars and
five gold pieces. As he proceeded,
I began to soften and
concluded to give the copper.
Another stroke of his oratory made me
ashamed of that and determined me to give
the silver.
And he finished so admirably that I
emptied my whole pocket into the dish,
the gold and all.
So even Franklin sort of has to admire
and ultimately contributed to what's
going on there.
So even this sort of true man of the
enlightenment found himself affected by
this oratory.
Okay.
So what was the impact of such great
awakening sentiment in the colonies?
Well, in part, given the distinctive
state of affairs and the colonies,
it's suggested to people that they had
the personal ability to change their
lives through their own freewill.
It was personally empowering and in that
sense it was sort of a democratizing
force.
I almost hesitated when I was writing
this to use the word democratizing cause I
didn't want to be.
And as I mentioned on that first day,
you put the democracy word out there
and all kinds of lights go off.
But I just couldn't
think of a better word.
So democratizing all stick with also
the great awakening preached spiritual
equality and included women,
African Americans and the poor
and the power of making choices.
Though the impact of that as we'll
see might not have been so great.
Plus,
it was an anti authoritarian force led
by Unorthodox preachers and people not
attached to an established church.
So we have here a mix of individualism
and personal empowerment and throw in
emotional sort of righteousness.
That's a really kind of a heady mixture
of feelings and ideas that would
eventually help to encourage a real
spirit of political resistance.
Okay. I'm going to mention a few more
basic things about colonial life that were
different from England very quickly.
First,
the realities of living on a frontier
which not only fostered a sense of
independence but also
a sense of community,
partly in a defensive way because of
fears about Indians and because of the
difficulties of forging a homestead or
creating a community of more positive
side colonist generally had healthier
living conditions than in England.
Food was plentiful.
There were plenty of open spaces and you
can actually see this concretely when
you look at the average size of an
English man and an English woman and a
colonial man, a colonial woman towards
the term, the middle of the 18th century.
Basically the average size
of an Englishman in the
middle of the 18th century
was five foot six and the,
this made me happy.
The average size of an English woman
was five feet, which is basically me.
It makes me so happy to think there's
a time when I was average height,
I feel so tall.
Um,
however colonial men and women on average
tended to be a couple of inches taller
so you could see plentiful
food wide open spaces.
Actually people are healthier and bigger,
which was true also among soldiers.
As a matter of fact, which was
interesting. You could see it.
This brings us to the third major
category of things that contributed to the
difference differences in being
a British American colonists.
So we've had the type
of person who migrated.
We just had a whole bunch of
living conditions in the colonies.
This is the third category,
which is the nature of the British
administration of the colonies,
which as I mentioned last
week was kind of light handed.
So colonial government and society could
develop in ways that Britain might not
necessarily have desired
or even recognized.
One of the most striking effect of this
lack of imperial control was the power
of the typical colonial
legislature left alone.
The colonists developed strong
legislatures which often were full of very
contentious individuals who felt
entitled and compelled to fight for their
rights. For what I discussed last
week, their English liberties.
Some of these colonial legislatures were
so strong that they often one battles
against royal governors battles that were
not taken much note of by the crown at
the time because the crown
wasn't administering to the
colonies very closely and
in fact by the 1760s most of the colonies
had in place all of the conditions
necessary to be self governing states.
They had elective assemblies and other
institutions of local government with and
these institutions had broad powers over
the internal affairs of the colonies.
They had a reservoir of political
leaders drawn from the elite.
And colonist recognized and we're jealous
of their power of self government and
we're not shy about fighting
royal officials for this power.
So by the 1760s there's a lot of things
in place for these colonies in a sense
to be self governing,
although obviously they are not already.
So in summary,
what does all of this add up to?
What do I mean when I refer to
being a British American? Well,
we've talked about a tradition of
voicing opinions and grievances.
We've talked about a sense of
entitlement to owning property and land.
We've talked about assumptions about
active participation in the political
process.
We've talked about a willingness to take
risks and fight for what you wanted.
We've talked about an independent spirit
and jealousy about your independence
and we've talked about relative tolerance
of ethnic and religious diversity.
You can hear this sort of
mixture of things in a comment
by a British officer in
the colonies during the French and
Indian war and he observed and wrote back
home just the nature of this people to
do all in their power to pull down every
legal authority. There is no
law prevailing at present here.
That's a little bit of an
exaggeration I would say,
but it's another arrogant British quote.
I promise you.
Lots of Eric and British quotes.
There is no law prevailing at
present here that I have met with,
but the rule every man pleases
to lay down to himself.
Every man insists upon following the
dictates of his own will without control.
A little bit of an exaggeration,
but you can see certainly what he feels
like he's seeing as compared with what
he knows from back in England
or as a member of the Massachusetts
legislature put it are people who are not
calculated to be kept in
any particular service.
They seem go troublesome,
an uneasy by reflecting upon their folly,
by bringing in,
bringing themselves into
a state of subjection when
they might've continued free
and independent. Now that sounds
like a sort of wonderful, you know,
thing impressive, admirable
like, oh our people are,
they like to be independent and if they
commit to something, they're not happy,
but that committee because they think,
wow, I could've been free and independent.
What have I done?
The problem with that is try putting a
bunch of those people into an army and
then expecting them to stay in
it for a long period of time.
George Washington was not a happy camper
for part a good part of the revolution
because he was stuck with a lot of
soldiers who had that point of view like,
well, I'll do this for a little
while and then I'll leave.
So it's kind of hard to command
that kind of an army is, we'll see.
And I guess I can't say I'm proud to
say. Um, Connecticut was a problem.
Connecticut as we'll see, Connecticut
head issues. Rhode Island too,
I think I mentioned that in the
first lecture, but Connecticut,
two soldiers particularly had
problems wanting to stick around,
but that was a general problem as well.
This sort of spirit of independence
and I've done what I wanted to do.
I'm going to now do something different.
So we've looked at being
a British colonist,
we've looked at being a British American.
The next step that we're going to be
taking on Thursday is going to be looking
at intercolonial relations, looking at
how the colonies felt about each other,
looking at how the colonies
interacted with each other,
how they felt about each other,
what their sense was of any kind of
cooperation or union between these sort of
colony states.
And by the end of Thursday's lecture,
we're going to see the first glimmers
of tension with the passage of the stamp
act. So by the end of the next lecture,
you can see why when I mentioned in that,
in that first lecture that
there was someone in when
I first taught this course,
who raised his hand probably at
the end of this lecture and said,
where are all the dates? Right? We've had
two lectures without a lot of dates. Um,
but the stamp app,
we have an actual concrete thing coming
on Thursday and then actual events of
the revolution.
Um,
but hopefully with these three lectures
you have some kind of a sense of,
of the sort of foundation of where we're
working from as we're now going to show
people basically getting upset,
working themselves,
a logic of resistance and
then acting on that logic. Um,
I think it's important obviously to
understand where the colonists were coming
from before you plunge right into seeing
them rebelling against what they've had
and for something else. But I think
certainly in these two first lectures,
you do get a sense of some of the ways
in which the colonies were prepared to
resist or maybe be predisposed to resist
and some of the reasons why it took
actually as you'll see a pretty long
time for the colonists to decide to
actually rebel.
Then it took a while.
People sort of let go finger by
finger of the British empire.
They let go piece by piece until finally
they felt that there was no alternative
except a revolution. I will end
there. I will see you on Thursday.
Um,
if you have questions,
come up and see me now at the end of
class or email them to me and I will see
you on Thursday.